[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
bienvenidos escala en París una emisión
de radio Francia internacional en
colaboración con la televisión France 24
en español en la que cada semana damos
la palabra a personas del mundo de las
ciencias las artes la cultura la
política los deportes y claro está de la
sociedad civil hoy nos acompañan dos
personas apasionadas de la poesía y de
chile están con nosotros Leticia abusaj
y santini traductores al francés de 2
gigantes de la literatura chilena
estamos hablando de Gabriela Mistral y
Raúl Zurita laiticia bozal bienvenida a
esta escala en París Muchas gracias Un
placer tenerla con nosotros ven nuevas
santini un placer Igualmente igualmente
Bienvenido a esta escala en París
Gabriela Mistral y Raúl Zurita son dos
autores que han trascendido su vida y
las fronteras del país que los vieron
nacer pero sin duda son dos personas que
no son conocidas de todo el mundo
Leticia muy brevemente Quién fue
Gabriela Mistral Gabriela Mistral
conocida como lucir algodón el verdadero
nombre
allí nació en 1889 en el norte chico y
era una mujer de origen muy Modesto
empezó a dar clases cuando era
adolescente a los 14 años y después tuvo
varios cargos de directora antes de
tener cargos diplomáticos cuando ella
fue directora conoció a Pablo Neruda Y
entonces lo animó y alentó a escribir y
a continuar con esa labor poética luego
viajó por el mundo tuvo cargos
diplomáticos en en y e hizo conferencias
en Estados Unidos en México Francia
Italia y obviamente obtuvo el premio
Nobel literatura en 1945 primer autor
latinoamericano en recibir ese premio
prestigioso
Raúl Zurita es un gran poeta nació en
1950 empezó a producir en los años 70
con su primer libro purgatorio y no no
dejo nunca de publicar de escribir
poesía ensayos y también de relatos
relatos autobiográficos por ejemplo y es
un poeta internacionalmente reconocido
recibió un montón de galardones el más
reciente es el premio Federico García
Lorca de literatura de poesía recibido
en Granada Hace unos días y fue
traducido a múltiples idiomas por eso
nos pareció pertinente con Leticia
traducirlo al francés y darlo a conocer
en nuestro país efectivamente son dos
personajes que ustedes se han ocupado de
traducirlos desde hace tiempo hay que
recordar que notablemente en el caso de
Gabriela Mistral hace más de 30 años que
hubo la última traducción de ella que
explica este retraso o esta posible
falta de atención de interés en la
traducción de Gabriela Mistral Leticia
las traducciones efectivamente en
francés eran bastante anticuadas Y
quizá porque importancia la poesía se
lee bastante poco y por eso a nosotros
nos pareció fundamental volver a
proponer traducciones más actuales y más
que puedan interesar al lector hoy día
estamos hablando en el caso de la
traducción de Gabriela Mistral de una
antología de poesía y prosa que ustedes
han traducido y en el caso de Raúl
Zurita de una de sus obras más recientes
precisamente purgatorio purgatorio del
79 Sí sí sí exactamente ahora bien Yo
quisiera preguntar cómo hace uno un
traductor para precisamente trasladar
una poesía tan complicada tan dolorosa
tan atormentada tan imaginativa como
puede ser la de Gabriela Mistral y sobre
todo la de Raúl Zurita claro es un
arresto Ah porque el traductor se
enfrenta el traductor de poesía se
enfrenta una serie de dificultades la
concisión formal en particular y en el
de Zurita El trastorno sintáctico el uso
de neologismos en ambos casos los
arcaísmos empleados por Gabriela Mistral
para trasladar al texto político el
habla campesina Así que a nosotros nos
importa mucho respetar también estas
peculiaridades del texto fuente y es un
trabajo minucioso que nos obliga a dejar
reposar también el texto para luego
volver a este mismo texto y hacer una
serie de a tomar una serie de decisiones
y es por eso nos parece importante
también este trabajo en común este
trabajo a cuatro manos justamente
Leticia hacer una traducción de estas es
vivir al poeta a la persona que se está
traduciendo no solo interpretarla sino
entrar en cada una de sus palabras pero
a propósito de lo que Raúl señala Perdón
venía señala
hay que es más fácil hacer una
traducción a cuatro manos que a dos
manos es diferente
trabajar a cuatro manos es una
experiencia muy enriquecedora porque nos
permite cruzar nuestras miradas a partir
de un punto de vista y una postura
traumatológica común entonces nuestras
miradas se complementan Podemos
intercambiar debatir y ponernos de
acuerdo y también escuchamos el texto a
nosotros nos importa mucho que el texto
suene bien en francés Entonces lo leemos
en voz alta siempre y lo dejamos reposar
lo volvemos a releer entonces hay una
forma de riqueza de que surge de esa
complementariedad en el trabajo en la
poesía hay muchas palabras que se
inventan hay un mundo que que se expresa
a través de las palabras de que no esté
escribiendo en este caso bueno en el
caso de Gabriela Mistral ella ya murió
en el caso de Raúl Zurita está vivo
usted comentaron que Precisamente en
algunas ocasiones le consultan a él para
intentar encontrar el justo medio la
palabra precisa que van a traducir claro
Raúl primero Raúl nos nos dio su
confianza es decir que que que que
Bueno estamos en contacto frecuente con
él y nos contesta muy amablemente y de
manera detallada cuando tenemos alguna
duda por ejemplo cuando hay alguna
evocación muy particular de una realidad
chilena pues le le escribimos él nos
contesta nos da una serie de
informaciones entonces también le
estamos muy agradecidos por por esta
esta confianza que que que nos da la
noticia Ustedes han estado varias veces
en Chile me decían que conocen
personalmente precisamente a Raúl es una
persona que yo lo veo con una persona
atormentada si se puede decir fue
detenido por la dictadura militar
chilena se quemó la cara como un hierro
caliente que recuerdo un poco al
personaje de Van Gogh un momento dado
este sufrimiento
permanente Cómo viven ustedes este Cómo
cómo repercute eso al momento de
Traducir su poesía
la la
tormenta digamos la el dolor que puede
tener que puede sentir Raúl aparece en
en su estilo por el trastorno por por
esa escritura y es fundamental volver a
traducirla y a hacerla viajar al francés
respetando lo mejor posible con
fidelidad esa esas posturas y pero
cuando cuando uno conoce a Raúl lo que
salta la vista es su generosidad
absoluta no y y y
su apoyo permanente también
hay dos cosas que unen a Raúl Zurita a
Gabriela Mistral son personas que
nacieron en la pobreza hay un compromiso
político de ambos o un compromiso
político de ambos hay algo que se
repercuta en el chile de hoy en la
figura de estos dos personajes Sí bueno
Raúl tiene relaciones muy estrechas con
las nuevas generaciones poéticas que
porque representa Pues un poeta inmenso
un modelo para las generaciones jóvenes
y como lo decía Leticia también
manifiesta mucha generosidad con
respecto a los poetas jóvenes les tiende
la mano hace presentaciones de los
poemarios de estos jóvenes emergentes de
estos poetas emergentes Así que
Efectivamente es una figura muy
importante para las nuevas generaciones
y es por ejemplo el padre espiritual de
un poeta importante también que tiene
unos 40 años que sector Hernández
Montesinos Y ambos tienen una relación
de amistad muy fuerte y entonces
efectivamente creo que la relación de
Raúl con Los poetas jóvenes es muy muy
estrecho y en cuanto a Gabriela Mistral
Efectivamente es un poco el estandarte
también de los poetas actuales en
particular respuestas homosexuales o las
poetas mujeres que encuentran en ella
también un modelo que seguir por todo el
compromiso por su lucha por los derechos
de la mujer en particular en su época
entonces son dos figuras efectivamente
fundamentales de la literatura
latinoamericana noticias son 60 años que
separan a uno de otro eh simplemente es
mucho tiempo y al mismo tiempo lo que
importa en este caso lo que me llamó
mucho la atención es si se habla poco de
precisamente Gabriela Mistral por sus
posiciones comprometidas un poco de
vanguardia con respecto a las mujeres no
usted decía hizo diplomacia
evidentemente fue diplomática háblenos
un poco de eso sí pero
el compromiso de Gabriela Mistral sigue
muy muy actual como lo acaba de decir se
pueden encontrar murales con la figura
de Gabriela mistrales es decir que en la
lucha actual por el reconocimiento a la
educación sobre todo porque ella luchó
mucho para ella la educación era
fundamental entonces sigue siendo de
completamente de actualidad su discurso
es muy contemporáneo Gabriela Mistral
empieza a escribir a los 15 años sino
mal recuerdo es a los 19 que decide
cambiarse de nombre
de asumir el nombre de Gabriela Mistral
recuerdennos por qué esa elección de
ella Ella eligió el nombre de Gabriela
Mistral por el poeta francés Federico
Mistral aquí en ella
consideraba mucho y era lo admiraba
Entonces era esa también los puentes
existen entre entre Mistral y los poetas
franceses entre chile y Francia y al
mismo tiempo ella fue la primera autora
latinoamericana en obtener el premio
Nobel en este caso absolutamente un gran
reconocimiento para ella que finalmente
se pasó la vida viajando y las
relaciones con chile fueron a veces
bastante difíciles recibió el premio
Nobel antes de recibir el premio
Nacional de literatura en Chile lo que
muestra que finalmente el reconocimiento
internacional precedió al reconocimiento
nacional hay una cosa que llama mi
atención en el caso de Zurita es un
autor para mi gusto no siempre fácil de
leer hay que verdaderamente
introducirse en lo que nos quiere decir
hay una palabra que ustedes han tenido
que utilizar que llamó mucho mi atención
es un poema que se llama domingo en la
mañana en la mañana y que comienza
diciendo me amanezco se ha roto una
columna y ustedes escriben que para
poder encontrar la palabra precisa
tuvieron que recurrir al francés antiguo
Sí porque me amanezco es un giro poco
frecuente entonces a nosotros como lo
decíamos hace unos minutos nos importa
también restituir las rarezas del del
texto o la originalidad del texto fuente
y entonces efectivamente optamos después
de debate sido en una reflexión profunda
optamos por
pero nos pareció corresponder entonces a
la expresión en español Leticia Quiénes
serían hoy Los Herederos precisamente de
Gabriela Mistral y de Raúl Zurita los
jóvenes poetas actuales siguen
recuperando estas figuras por ejemplo
reescriben poemas de Gabriela Mistral
en el caso de Pablo paredes y de Diego
Ramírez por ejemplo
y es más difícil saber para para Raúl
porque sigue escribiendo produciendo
mucho entonces él está todavía bien
digamos integrado en esos en esos medios
culturales actuales pero su su hijo
espiritual que es así como lo denomina
es Héctor Hernández Montesinos pues
llegamos ya al final de esta escala en
París no sino agradecer a Leticia abusar
ya venía su presencia en nuestros
estudios traductores de la obra de Raúl
Zurita y de Gabriela Mistral a ustedes
gracias por su atención y les damos una
nueva cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en París
[Música]